a New Jersey man charged with making
terroristic threats for intentionally
coughing on a grocery store worker while
claiming he had coronavirus let's bring
in Judge Andrew Napolitano Fox News
senior judicial analyst and the Deputy
Attorney General Jeffrey Rosen has
written this memo yesterday he says that
because coronavirus appears to meet the
statutory definition of a biological
agent such as acts potentially could
implicate the nation's terrorism related
statutes threats or attempts to use
covin 19 as a weapon against Americans
will not be tolerated so what do you
think about this judge could somebody be
charged with terrorism for coughing on
somebody and saying they have
coronavirus even if they don't well let
me give you both sides of the argument
this instance to which you're referring
occurred in a Wegmans supermarket down
the New Jersey Shore an area that I know
you're familiar with which outraged
governor Murphy the incident consisted
of some sort of a dispute between the
customer and the cashier the customer
coughed on the cashier and said oh and
by the way I have coronavirus that was
reported and he was arrested in ordinary
times he would be charged with a simple
assault meaning he didn't break her skin
in breaker bones but in this environment
where people are understandably
terrified about contracting this disease
it's unheard of to think that somebody
would intentionally give it to you so
did he intentionally cause a biological
agent to infect somebody else we don't
know the answer to that yet because we
don't know if he's positive and if he
wasn't then presumably the cashier is
not the problem with the government's
argument is the terror anti-terror
statutes have a couple of requirements
in there they require two or more acts
of violence intended to alter the
foreign policy of the United States who
knows what this guy in Wegmans was
thinking but it's quite a leap for the
government to prove that they'd be
better off charging him locking him up
because the courts are closed in New
Jersey I don't know how long he's going
to be locked
before even sees a judge and charged him
with this simple assault and wait and
see what the tests show is it similar to
pulling the fire alarm in a crowded
theater well I mean what he said caused
an enormous disturbance as you can
imagine it got the attention of the
attention of the governor governor
Murphy himself not a lawyer but the
chief law enforcement officer in the
state directed that he be charged under
New Jersey's anti-terror law which
mimics the language of the federal law
which also requires two or more acts of
violence intending to effect the the
foreign policy of the United States but
doing something like that in a public
place can cause tremendous pandemonium
and he would be liable for injuries that
occurred as a result of the pandemonium
saying a stampede from people who
watched and and and heard what he did to
this cashier right right of course don't
do it but these crises these tragedies
that we're living through now often
cause novel litigation because that
prosecution is you never thought of this
is one of them that's probably going to
get many more I don't think anybody's
going to be prosecuted until the crisis
has passed and there's some general
agreement about how to treat these cases
all right judges in Politan and we
appreciate learning from you as always
thank you pleasure Tina